あ すいません 中部経典に鋸の譬という小経ですか
という経典がありまして
そこで悪い人間が来て
自分の体を拘束して鋸で切られるけれども
怒りを出してはいけないというところがありまして
で そのこの西方経という
今説明していただいたところでですね
その体を捕まえて切るっていうのがその究極の不非非情さ害で
で その切られても怒りひと掛けの起こさないというのは
この究極の阿鼻非情さだとするとですね
その西方経が確か十経典の十九番目で
鋸の譬の方が何番だったか近い番号だったと思うんですけども
すごいこうリンクしてるっていうか
その西方経でその実際の分類をして
その鋸の譬の方で実際の実例がストーリーとして出てるような気がするんですけども
その並びは何か関係あるんでしょうか
まああの鋸の譬というのは決してありえないことですから
あの それはただ聞いただけで
覚えただけで心は怒りはなくなるでしょ
だから そこは基準にして生活しなさいというと
それだけでも完了しますよ
だから仏典っていうのは並べなくてもいいんで
一個一個もう完了していますから
ある人が鋸の経典しか勉強したことがないとしても
その人は完全に仏教を知っていることになります
今日はもっと心理学的に丁寧にお釈迦様実践を踏まえてお坊さんたちが実践しているし
それでお釈迦様自分の経験も教えながらした授業みたいな説法を選んだんですね
だから自分が先生であることも強調しているんです
そういうところでは 先生たるものにはできることは全部やっているんだよと
あなた方はそれから実践するだけだと
だから語る場合は完全に語るんですよ
それだけで覚えて森に入れば十分です
またまたまたまた来る必要はないんです
私の話みたいに何回聞いたってすぐ忘れちゃうしね
それはもういい先生じゃないんですね
お釈迦様の場合はそうじゃないんです
そうそうできないんです
一回の面会でもう悟りに達するんだからね
そのポイントしか経典として残ってないんですよ
だから今日のスライドもね
流しちゃえばまあ十五分で流せますけど
読みながらね しかし説明するともう二時間もかかってしまっちゃってね
そんなもんでしょうと
お釈迦様の教えも だからすごいやと思いますよ
もうものすごいと思いますね
お釈迦様の指導の力と先生としてのパワーというのはね
だからまあ並びとかなんとかそうか
まあどうすればいいのか気にしなくていいと
とにかく今日は知識的に授業のスタイルで
心理学的に丁寧に分析して
どのように思考を育てていくのかっていう整理整頓の話なんです
他になかったか じゃあ帰ってきました
すいません  二つお願いします
えーと 欲に関する思考をやめるっていうことなんですが
あ ん 欲に関する  はいはい
思考をやめるっていうことなんですが
えーと たとえ話で旅行したいとか成功したいっていうのがあったんですが
私は旅行したいと思っているんですけど
うん なんか旅行したいっていうのがないと
どこどこに行こうとか
そういう計画ができないと思うんですが
こういうのをどう考えたらいいんでしょうかということと
あと やっぱり私の問題として
妄想がすごいっていうのが問題で
特に怒りの妄想 怒りに関する妄想が激しくて
すごい困って いろんなことをしてもなかなかその切り替えがうまくいかない
いかなくて どうも引きずってしまうっていうのがすごく問題なんですが
それはどうしたらいいでしょうか
お願いします  どうしたらって言ったっても
やめるしかないでしょうね
あの理由考えないでやめることなんですね
あの１回説法で言いましたからね
やっぱりこれは自己破壊だからね
かっこ悪いんですよね
なんでわざわざと もう猿みたいにゴリラみたいにね
生活するんですかね だからまあせいぜい美しい動物になった方がいいでしょうね
パンダみたいにね だからなんでパンダよりはゴリラになってしまうのかとかね
そういうことで この怒りの思考などなどはすごくかっこ悪くて
自己破壊的で 例えば旅行に行っても楽しくないんですよ
何かに文句つけますからね
で やっぱり感情的に楽しくなることもダメ
欲ですからね やっぱり人間を理解するとかね
いろいろ環境を学ぶとかね
いろんな経験を得るとかね
もうちょっとしっかりした人間になろうではないかというふうな方向へ持っていかなくちゃいかんですよ
だから欲の思考というのは
もうまあ旅行したいとかね
まあ次何しようかなとかね
そういうふうにも楽しみばっかしか
いわゆる刺激ですね 快楽ですね
快楽快楽のことばっかし計画立てると
計画自体は思考ですよ
妄想じゃないんです それは一番最初に説明しました
妄想はもう断然ダメです
旅行したいならばちゃんと計画を立てなくちゃいけないんですね
それが思考なんですね
ちゃんと結論があります
いつ出発するか いつ帰るか
どんな飛行機に乗るか
あれこれやとかね どこで泊まるかとか出ますからね
だからそれでその思考が終了するんですね
だからといって 思考も妄想も仏教はもうダメなものだと言ってますから
それはじわじわと自分を育てるしかないんですね
1 日で治ろうと思ったら
これはちょっと成り立たないんだから
今 幼稚園のレベルから教えたんですけど
お釈迦さんの幼稚園というのはかなり大変だからね
幼稚園にならないんですけど
で この順番で頑張ってみればいいんじゃないかなと思います
とにかく怒りは良くないんですね
やっぱりかっこ悪いんですよ
ありがとうございます
では マイク回してありますので
どうぞ  えっとですね 六怒り以外に音楽というか
鼻歌というか そういったものが頭に流れて
そこから漏れるみたいなことがあると思うんですけど
その位置づけと 私にはそういう愚痴というようなことになるのかなと思ってるんですけども
怒りというよりも 勝手に流れる音楽は無知なのかなというふうに考えてもいるんですが
これは一体その六怒り愚痴っていう位置づけから方向にあたるのかということと
実際それが流れて困る時に理由がないので
どのように対処したらいいのかということを教えていただきたいんですけど
あの大丈夫でしょうね
まあずっと私はもう苦労して喋ったのは
もう一度話をちょっと考えておけば
ノートメモを書いたならばね
大丈夫ですよ 書いたのは釘
太い釘を細い釘で抜くようにとかね
いろいろあるいは妄想自体がね
まあヘビの死骸のような感じで
ああ 気持ち悪い これはとかね
そういうふうなことで抑えた方がよろしいんですね
これだったら病気になりそうとかね
今言ったように 例えば頭の中で音楽はもうガンガン流れてる場合でも
ちょっと病気になってしまう可能性はないとは言えませんね
音楽家プロは別ですけど
プロは作品を作って金儲かってますから
それは思考に入るんですね
だから我々はみんなすごい不公平な思考で生きてますから
毒 蛇の毒と同じなんです
蛇にとってはありがたいことですけど
我々にとってはもうあまりの迷惑ということにもなったりするし
だから科学者は科学思考で
音楽家は音楽思考で食べているんですね
それだけのことで で 解脱を仏教の目的から見ると
悪思考にはなります 音楽も欲に入ります
で 思考の自由がないということは
感情が激しい場合はもうどうしようもなくノンストップで思考しちゃうんですね
その場合は何としてでもこの循環を切るんですよ
切る方法は 5つ教えましたから
もう 一番わかりやすいのは 5番目なんです
何としてでも逆立ちしてでも止めると
そういう苦行の方がわかりやすいので
お釈迦様は最後に入れたんです
あまりにも激しい場合はね
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば いきなり怒りが込み上げてきたらね
カッとなったらもうどうにもならんですね
若い人々はもう人殺しまでやっちゃいますからね
我々はもう年寄りだからね
そんな簡単に体を動けませんだけど
しかし その代わりに体壊れるんです
だから その場合は怒りが込み上げてきたら
もう何でもいいんだからね
階段から落ちてもいいんですよ
ゴロゴロゴロと で ひどい
痛くて痛くてたまらん
だからね あの怒りはひとたまりもなく消えちゃいます
そんなひどいことをやらなくても
何とかしてね いるでしょ
時々なんか冷たい水を体にかぶったりとかね
その気持ちを何とかしようとかね
で それは仏教では 5番目の最後の手段で
まあ優しく順番で語ってはいるんですね
本当は何か変な思考が入ると
別なことを思考する 電車の例で言ったでしょ
電車に乗ったら何か綺麗な美人でも見て
なんかどんどんあー綺麗な人だな
あれやこれと思っちゃうと
これ危ないんですよ それだったらもうそこを見ないで
さっさと本を取って本を読む
別なことする そういうやり方でこの流れをカットするんですよ
どうしても思考自体が基本的には悪になるんです
どんな思考でも 新しい良いこの車開発しようと思っても欲なんですよ
だからこれはもう全て思考をストップするしか答えがないんです
では みんな思考停止に成功したらどうなるかというと
別にどうにもなりませんよ
ものすごい世界はものすごい幸福になるだけです
だから悪思考をやめると
その代わりに脳が動いてますからね
今は想像できない すごい次元が変わって動くんです
例えば欲がなくても音楽は作れますよ
欲がない人は作る音楽で人間がお互いに心配すること
優しくなることを学ぶんで
亡くなったマイケルジャクソンさんとかね
あの欲だけ引き起こす
まあまあ 芸術家としてはもうものすごい能力ですけど
で とにかく欲ばっかし引き起こす作品ばっかしでしたでしょ
で  We Are The World という歌を作ったんですね
みんなで 私はどんな音楽よりも
あの曲を聴くとすごく楽しくなるんです
すごいなと思うんですよ
マイケルジャクソンのフレーズでも
We Are The World というフレーズを歌っている時はすごい感動するんです
なんて美しい声だなと
それ声だけではなくて
そこでこの愛というか
慈しみを歌っているんですね
We Are The World
みんな同じだと それは金も取ってないんだから
あの曲を作る場合はね
一流のみんな集めてもうやりましたからね
あっちかどこかの子供たちを助けるためのね
援助を集めるために だからあの能力
同じ能力はもうそうやって人を助けるためにも使えます
普通は金儲けるためでしょ
だからそんな美しくないんです
で 私に聞けばね どんな音楽好きかと
何一つ好きじゃないんです
気持ち悪いんです だから可哀想だと思いますよ
能力あるんですよ 能力あるんだけど
もう金儲けだけ狙ってるんだから
ヒットすることだけ狙ってるんだから
何かもう慈しみに基づいてやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
慈しみが出てくると結構仕事はできます
だから音楽でも欲がなくなるとすごいいい音楽は出ます
怒りがなくなると素晴らしい音楽が出てくるんです
科学的な開発も矛盾だらけの危険だらけの開発でなくなっちゃうんです
で 今我々にはイメージできない
なぜならば 人類には悪思考しかないんだからね
だから私に具体的にあの人のこの人のこととはちょっと言いづらいんですけど
そういうことで 仏道では危険性はゼロですからね
善思考でダメになったってありえないんです
思考を止めること 止めることで大変なことになった
これはもうありえないんです
それは断言できますね
2500年も仏教は問題作ってないんです
仏教は仏教だと思って
この恐ろしい邪教を語っている人々は問題作ってますよ
特に日本ではね たくさん新興宗教システムがありまして
自分の宗教だから自分の名前で言えばいいのに
どこかで仏教の乗り物に乗るんですね
あれ 金儲けのためなんですね
だから仏教の名前を出しちゃうと
どうもそれから金を集めて金を集めて邪見を教えてあげて
みんなを地獄に陥れるというね
我はブッダであるというバカもいるんだからね
我は釈迦であるとか 想像もできない
私にはどこまで悪人かと
で 韓国から来たなんとか統一教会とかね
日本に来たら仏教なんで
あれ カトリック キリスト教の新興宗教なんですけど
プロテスタントの 日本に来たら観音さんよりあれやこれやとか
壺を売ったり いろんなことをやったりとかね
だから仏教はすごいんだから
仏教という一言葉で もうだからお釈迦様だけすごい禁止しているんで
仏教はもう金儲けに絶対使ってはならんやと
人気のために絶対使ってはならんと知識のために学んではならんと
禁止なんです だから盗人ばっかりですよ
みんな 仏教は人々の幸福のために
人々の悩み苦しみなくすために教えるものなんです
で まあ自由な宗教だから
誰かが仏教を仏教と言い張ったってもどうしようもないんですよ
これは仏教にあるちょっと問題なんですね
人が自由に本を取って読んで
我は仏教だと言ったら
もうどうしようもないんですけどね
だからまだ仏教だけはカトリック教会
ローマ教会みたいな管理がないんですね
誰も もう信じられないぐらい自由なんです
我々は誰も管理してないんです
本山にいつでも報告して
こういうことこういうことで許可もらったりとかないんです
だからといって誰もいい加減なことは言いませんし
間違ったことは言いませんし
献身的に頑張っている
それは仏教だけのもうすごいこと
私も社会学的にこれっておかしいと思う時もありますよ
管理がなく うまく管理されていることは
政府がなく 国がうまくいっていると言ったらありえないでしょうに
警察官がなく 警察システムがなく
みんな見事にうまくいってるんだと言ったらすごい
ありえないんですよ 仏教の場合は
それはもうものの見事にそれを見せてるんですね
この世界の道を歩みなさいと
見てみなさいよと 問題は起こりませんよと
だから私たちは思考を止めることに散々言いますけど
止めない場合は止められない場合は慈しみでいるんです
いつでも小さな虫一匹でも幸福でありますようにという気持ちで生きているんですね
それでも OK ですよ しかし
お釈迦様にはそれでも疲れますよと
だから思考は完全に止めて解脱しましょうというのがブッダの道なんですね
ちょっと余計なことを脱線して喋りましたけど
あの まあ一応頑張ってみてください
あの方法で  はい ありがとうございます
そろそろちょっと時間が押してきましたので
あとひと方も 今質問された方も後ろの方に手を挙げていますので
ちょっと前に回せていただけますか
えっと 別のカテゴリーが一つ一つでまとめられているんですけど
怒りはそのヴィパッサナーのところ
で 統一する害のところっていう２つチェックポイントを悪思考で与えているっていうのはどういうことなんでしょうか
ちょっと意味が通じなかったんですけど
悪思考で 欲だったら欲と一つだけのグループでまとめておけるのに
怒りのグループに属するものが
そのヴィパッサナーとその美人美女さんと 2つ
そのチェックポイントを設定しているというのは
どういうふうな意図が通っているんでしょうか
それはね どうしてでしょうかね
私たちは疑問に思わないんですね
これはもう純粋な仏説ですからね
八正道でそう分析しています
これはもう全くも異論ないんですね
どんな注釈書でも どこでも疑問があったら必ずディスカッションしますよ
仏教では これはもうどうにもならん
もう純粋にお釈迦様の生の仏説教えそのものなんです
だからお釈迦様がものすごい精密すぎただからね
思考の管理の場合は真偽と外衣というふうに 2つに分けちゃったんですね
でおそらくおそらく私の感想しか言えませんだけど
これは仏教の世界ではディスカッションしてないんだから
私にちょっとあの昔のね
もう紀元前の時代でディスカッションしていないと
阿羅漢たちがね もう私には何とも言えませんからね
この害っていうのは真偽がなくても起これるんでしょ？じゃあ魚釣りは何ですかね
釣りっていうのは日本語
日本では趣味でしょうね
テレビではね あの公の電波を使って 1時間
2時間も流してるんだからね
だから私にとってはとてもいい勉強になりますよ
いかにこの連中 アホでバカでというかね
すごい苦労して ものすごい寒い時もね
もう指でも触れたくない寒い水の中に入ったりして釣りをするとかね
で その時は怒りはないでしょ
ただ害を与えるだけなんですね
どうしたら魚釣れるのかとかね
餌は何なのかと あ この餌の代わりに疑似餌作ったりとかね
明らかに害なんですね
あの日本でこの牛を飼っている人々は
牛を子供のようにえらい可愛がって育てますけどね
でも 2歳  2  3  2歳  3歳になったらもう売っちゃいますね
だからあんた牛のこと嫌いかというと
そうじゃないんですよ
好きなんですけど 可愛がってもあげたりもする
しかし じゃあ明日っていうことになったら
もう車に入れて もうトラックに入れて持っていくんです
だからそれはもう明らかに害でしょ
だから私は言ったんでしょ
生きること自体が弱者いじめで殺しでしょうと
我々は生きているということは
他の生命を潰してその材料を体に入れてるんだからね
これは怒りあろうがなかろうがやってますからね
例えば この漁師の人々とかね
あの自然がなくなることはすごい大変なことやと思いますね
ダム作るなよとかね こんなことやるなよとかね
もう自然が壊れますよとかね
どこかであの生命を怒ってないんですね
サンマのこと イワシのことは大嫌いやとか
見たくもないんだと怒ってないんです
ああ サンマの大群が来ましたと言って
もう豊作 豊作というんですか
え？大量大量と言って取っちゃいますね
もうとんでもない害でしょ
暴力でしょ 命取ってるんだから
そこでイワシなんかは少なくなってくると随分悩んだりして
もう自然が破壊だから
あれだから これだからこうなってるんだと言って
もうその生命のことを心配までするということだから
分けたんじゃないかなと思います
以上です うん それも私の感想ですけどね
だからほどほどに取ってください
ありがとうございます
それでは回向の文を皆さんでお唱えして終わらせてもらいます
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
海を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨー イワンジャントー サンバローゴー ウィナッサトー マテー バワントアンタラーヨー スキーディーナ
ー ユコーバワー バワトゥ サッベマンガラン ラッカントゥ サンバデーヴァタ サンバブンダヌバーヴェーナ サンバダンマー
ヌバーヴェーナ サッベサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティバワントゥテー アビワダナシーリス ニッチャン ワッダ
パチャイノー チャッタルーダンマー ワッダンティー アユワノー スカンバラン
はい ありがとうございます